have either of you played heads up I've
played heads up oh my God yes we are
gonna play a MCU version cool heads up
it's fun and it's it's easy okay good
exactly
you're competing with the other rooms
we're on the same we're on the same team
oh okay you want me to go first and I
can demo it yes yes please okay on your
marks get set go green Hulk
oh
[Music]
there's a good clue for that one pass
oh um I keep growing
limbs Groot yeah
oh God I I really think I'm I'm I'm big
and I tend to use an Implement yes
[Music]
um all right yes I really need to see
the dentist
um I'm kind of big I don't move around
really easily uh the tips yeah
he's just such a really nice actor who
tends to think he's the sweetest
everyone loves him Chris Pratt no he's
sort of you know if you you looked in
the mirror you might see who he is you
know
yeah yeah yeah my guy oh the best
addition to the MCU definitely but his
character would be
oh a high evolutionary there you go
six so so far we're at six great you
guys are at six all right ready remarks
good set go all right
hello um I almost said it
um pass okay yeah
um
what
um okay
um uh oh like uh pass sorry
um oh okay
um uh bow and arrow oh uh Hawkeye um no
that would have been what I should have
said pass I'm sorry
oh no
is it did we get into the big leagues
oh well then it's a pass oh okay
oh Spiderman boom
um oh um uh he's got two knives and he's
uh he's very literal and he's like
purple and he's in this movie Yes
um ah don't know
go
um oh your best friend in the movie
uh in the dress yes
[Music]
oh he was in uh volume two and he had a
really funny name that everyone kept
making fun of the taser face
you gold guy in the movie
uh English you know oh my God what's the
name of the character
um uh yeah yeah uh you know uh
what
what of the in the little animals in
this movie no no remember Rocket's
brother but he had think of the mouth
um you know he named himself after uh
teeth yes
okay at me nebula
um who is that I don't know who that is
um
[Laughter]
uh oh Jesus okay Blanchette and um
you can't say actors names that was
right all right ready set go
what I don't know
oh uh she has a sword and also she has a
flying horse oh and the Pegasus woman oh
oh uh but he's in our movie he's the
villain oh
um
oh
um you know he directed uh no the movie
that we did in Australia uh
the character that he plays and he looks
like uh
yeah
I don't know what this is oh no what oh
no oh uh
um oh my God the character in our movie
that uh like he's like uh made out of
wood uh Groot yeah
um
um Avengers movies but uh no but also
like so you're you're either gonna win
or lose depending on how uh hell uh
Chris and James go
upstairs on Ready Set Go
um currently shooting mice by two uh
Dave Batista drags
uh uh hilarious
name
I believe is did you make attack a lot
Volume 2 Nemesis
Nemesis uh ego uh he is a ravager with a
stupid name for all that uh that rocket
makes fun of him laughs at his oh taser
face
Golden Boy uh Marla
walrus uh thiefs
[Music]
Scott
ish oh uh nebula all right yeah
[Music]
I don't know this time
all right so where that is we're at five
so now you hand the rest of the pile
with this one that he already saw that
oh you saw it let's get rid of that get
rid of that one Daryl okay do you know
who do I either you know who Daryl is no
nobody knows who Daryl is it's uh it's
the roommate that Thor gets oh
yeah we get in trouble with the ones
that aren't about us understand all
right um wait wait let me reset the
timer oh no okay all right ready set go
um can we pass you could pass pass it's
a it's Cape uh what's her name
Blanchette anyway
um uh uh oh uh uh a web Slinger
Spider-Man
uh uh it's a stone guy in Thor core
[Music]
uh I am Groot
uh Thor Woman sword Pegasus oh uh
Valkyrie
[Music]
um
Iron Man's sidekick actor from swingers
John Favreau he plays Uncle Leroy uh the
butler
Gary the butler you you need one more
pass
don't don't know
uh uh
what's what's Sparrow's character's name
happy Hogan
happy Hogan yeah
I just had a fit in front of everyone
[Music]
thank you